for decades and decades the united
states had
plenty of natural gas supplies domestic
gas that was
drilled from fields in texas and
oklahoma and all over the country really
in the
late 90s the drillers started having
trouble replacing the fields that they
had been producing from they found it
was getting harder
and harder to maintain our domestic
supplies of natural gas
i first heard about michael smith in the
early 2000s
when um entrepreneurs like himself
were starting to think oh man if we
can't get enough natural gas
in the united states domestically we're
going to have to get it from somewhere
else
a very few people who are who are
considering this if we can't get
domestic gas we're going to have to
import it from the rest of the world and
it's hard to import gas the trouble with
moving gas is that it's
you know it's gaseous how do you how do
you move
gas you put it in a pipeline usually um
but you can't have a pipeline that goes
from
oh the middle east all the way to the
u.s you have to
condense the gas so what they do to turn
um natural gas into liquefied natural
gas
is they build these enormous factories
that basically chill it down think of a
refrigerator
that is so cold that it will take the
air around you
and condense it 600 times and when you
shrink it and condense it it turns into
a liquid
and then you can pump that liquid into
basically a thermos and in this case
these thermoses are the size of
gigantic ships huge tankers
that are insulated and they can keep
the gas in its liquid state as it's
floating around the world
so what michael smith thought was oh you
know i've
found some really great locations on the
texas gulf coast
where we could import this lng
from other parts of the world we're
going to import the gas
and then re-gasify it turn it from a
liquid back into a gas and then just put
it into the u.s
pipeline network so that you know it can
replace the
domestic gas lng is the cleanest
uh fossil fuel and we're taking
us lng and exporting it to countries
that do not have enough energy and would
otherwise
be burning uh dirty coal or bunker fuel
which is also very bad for the
environment
so the quicker we can be all on natural
gas
until the day comes that uh we're
on renewables the better it is for uh
the environment global warming
he raised about 800 million dollars
mostly from conoco phillips
to uh to build this
regasification terminal the problem was
that as they were building this terminal
something happened in the united states
and that was the the fracking revolution
it's short for hydraulic fracturing
that's where drillers will go down two
miles into the earth
they'll drill sideways into a very thin
layer of shale
that is laden with oil or natural gas
you know no one knew that all of a
sudden
over the past 10 or 15 years that
drillers
would discover this method of
unlocking trillions upon trillions of
cubic feet
worth of domestic gas that we we never
knew was there
a lot of people don't like fracking
they're worried about the effect that
fracking could have on
groundwater supplies but the reality of
the situation is that
fracking has allowed us to unlock so
much natural gas
that we can displace the coal that we've
used
to in the past provide almost half of
america's electrical power
michael smith was building this project
to import gas
at the same time that america's frackers
were unlocking more gas than we ever
knew
existed in the united states by the time
it was completed
in 2008 they had a shiny new
import terminal and then they looked
around and said
oh no this is completely obsolete there
was no demand
for importing gas like they thought
there would be they decided that what
they would do
was be one of the first to
export liquefied natural gas from the
united states
to the rest of the world but it wasn't
that easy
he raised 800 million dollars to build
the
import terminal in order to build the
export terminal
he would need to raise 13 billion
dollars
there are very few construction projects
in the united states
that that have ever cost more than
freeport lng this is something you know
no one had
raised this much money before for a
project especially not
one that was really led and controlled
by a single individual
it's so impressive that they've they've
built this thing it's
you know bigger than any factory any
refinery you've
you've ever seen over the last year
freeport lng
has exported roughly 200
cargos of u.s gas in the form of lng
this is just a it's a tremendous
development
they found so much gas that now we can
send it around to the rest of the world
and help other countries not have to use
coal
as well there is still a billion people
in the world without electricity
and they want a piece of the pie that we
take for granted michael smith owns
roughly 60 of this all he was able to
hold on to control of the uh
of the majority of the equity in this
operation the forbes estimates right now
that michael smith is worth
roughly 1 billion the beauty of his
business
at freeport lng is that you don't just
build this export facility
and not have customers what they did
while they were lining up the financing
they convinced
these buyers in south korea
and japan and china to enter into
20-year contracts he knows how much
money
freeport lng is going to make pretty
much every year for the next two decades
so we have him at about a net worth of
one billion dollars right now
but this business will be generating so
much cash over the next few years
that they'll be able to pay off their
roughly 11 billion dollars
worth of debt that they're carrying and
after that
it's all gravy yeah assuming it all goes
right
there's you know there's still some risk
there um there could be a hurricane that
blows through
the united states gets roughly 20
of our electricity by combusting natural
gas in
in power plants because of all this gas
that we've discovered
the united states has been able to
reduce our carbon emissions tremendously
over the last 10 or 15 years so as coal
goes down
the use of gas is going up and that's
the case around the entire world
um thanks to the gas that we're
exporting
in the form of lng much of the lng
that flows out of the freeport
project goes to places like japan
and south korea and china and
one cargo of this lng can provide enough
gas to make the electricity that can
power
thousands and thousands of homes for
months at a time
if we're concerned about carbon
emissions
people see natural gas as kind of a
bridge a bridge that is taking us from
the old times of coal to
a future where we can hopefully rely
mostly on renewables
like solar and wind and other options
so gas is is that
very important bridge fuel that will get
us
to where we need to go